this is the largest wildfire of the year
in california
burning along the border with nevada a
combination of two
fires sparked by lightning it doubled in
size between friday and saturday
the fire's rolling downhill here it's
one of several fires threatening homes
across the western united states
blamed on so-called heat domes pockets
of high pressure which push warm air
down
forcing temperatures up this is jaw
jaw-dropping
those are the effects of climate change
it's here it's real
it's human-induced the impacts the acute
impacts are happening decades before
even the scientists have predicted
with scorching temperatures across 10
states 30 million americans are facing
extreme heat this wildfire in oregon
doubled in size on saturday pushed by
strong winds
officials have called the blaze
unpredictable and erratic
some areas have been evacuated while
others have been told to pack up and be
ready to leave
at any moment the heat and the fires
putting pressure on the power grid
people are being urged to conserve water
and electricity
old systems and they just tend to break
on hot days
they can't take the heat they overheat
there are warnings the dangerous
conditions could cause heat-related
illnesses
this latest surge follows the hottest
june on record for the u.s
and a historic heatwave estimated to
have killed nearly 200 people
the searing temperatures baking visitors
at california's joshua tree national
park
it's the hottest place on earth like
this is hot it's never been hotter
it feels like we're in an oven yeah
nearby death valley also
in the mojave desert reached 53 degrees
celsius on saturday
54 on friday if confirmed it would be
the highest recorded in more than a
century
and close to the highest ever measured
on earth
the conditions are so extreme and the
air so
dry that some of the water dropped by
aircraft to fight the fires
evaporates before it reaches the ground
forecasters say even if temperatures
don't continue to break records
the widespread oppressive and
long-lasting heat
remains a threat alex o'brien al jazeera